hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to
start off as I often do with a quote
this is from one of my favorite writers
of all time Kurt Vonnegut and it goes as
follows quote here is a lesson in
creative writing first rule do not use
semicolons
they are transvestite hermaphrodites
representing absolutely nothing all they
do is show that you've been to college
end quote
I have a habit of using dashes in the
same way so I like to read this to
remind me not to use that crutch also
pretty the adverb I overused that so in
any case Kurt Vonnegut lots of lessons
lots of amazing books if you need one to
start with go with cat's cradle
today's guest is Kevin Kelley Kevin
Kelley is one of the most interesting
human beings I have ever met he is a
dear friend and as for the bio Kevin
Kelley is senior maverick at Wired
magazine which he co-founded in 1993 he
also co-founded the all species
foundation a non-profit aimed at
cataloging and identifying every living
species on earth and in all his spare
time he writes best-selling books he
co-founded the Rosetta project which is
building an archive of all documented
human languages and he serves on the
board of the long now foundation which
I've been honored to join as a speaker
on one occasion as part of the long now
foundation he's looking into among other
things how to revive and restore
endangered or extinct species including
the woolly mammoth I'm not making this
stuff up Kevin is amazing this is going
to be a multi-part episode so there'll
be a number of different podcast
episodes because we went quite long this
is part one I hope you enjoy it you can
find all links show notes and so on
once we complete the entire series at
four hour work week com forward slash
podcast you can also find all previous
episodes I've done in this podcast for
our work week dot-com
forward slash podcast all spelled out
and put that further ado please enjoy
and thank you for listening
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question
now I see I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
heaven thank you so much for being on
the show it's my honor and I am
endlessly fascinated by all of the
varied projects that you constantly have
going on but that leads me to the first
question which is when you meet someone
who is not familiar with your background
and they ask you the age-old what do you
do question how do you even begin to
answer that what is your stock answer to
that these days my stock answer is is
that I package ideas into books in
magazines and websites hmm and I make
ideas interesting and pretty well I like
the pretty that's what we'll come back
to the aesthetic aspect I think that's a
really neglected piece of the entire
puzzle you do have of course a
background a lot of people are familiar
with your background with Wired but
perhaps you could give folks a bit of
background on yourself and is it true
that you you dropped out of college
after one year yeah I'm a college
dropout and actually my one regret in
life is that one year Oh No kidding no
yeah I wish I had just even skipped that
but I I do understand how college can be
useful to people and I've my own
children have gone through but for me it
was just not the right thing and I went
to Asia instead and I like to tell
myself that I gave my own self a PhD in
East Asian Studies mm-hmm by traveling
around and photographing very remote
remote parts of Asia at a time when it
was in a transition from the ancient
world to the modern world and I did many
other things as well and for me it was a
very formative time because I did enough
things that when I finally got my first
real job at the age of 35 Wow
which which job is that I worked for
nonprofit at $10 an hour which was the
Whole Earth Catalog which we had been
alike have a lifelong dream if I said if
I couldn't have a job that was a job I
want it took me a long time to kind of
get it but in between that I did many
things including starting businesses and
selling businesses and doing other kinds
of things more adventures and I highly
recommend it you know I got involved in
starting wired and running wired for a
while and I hired a lot of people who
were coming right out of college
there were interns they would do the
intern thing and then they were good and
we would hire them which meant that
basically you know after 10 years
whatever was they were this was their
first and only job and I kept telling
them why are you here what are you doing
you should be slowing around wasting
time trying something crazy why are you
working a real job I don't understand it
and I just really I really recommend
slack
I mean believer in in this thing of kind
of doing something that's not productive
you know practice for your Middle Ages
young want to be prolific and make and
do things but you don't want to measure
them in terms of productivity you want
to measure them in terms of extreme
performance you want to measure them in
kind of extreme satisfaction it's a time
to kind of try stuff and and I think
explore the extremes exactly explore the
possibilities and there are so many
possibilities and there's more every day
and and you don't want its called
premature organization you really you
really want to use this time to continue
to do things and by the way premature
optimization is a problem of success not
just the problem of the young it's the
problem of the successful more than even
at the young but we'll get to that yeah
that's that might turn into a therapy
session for me at this precise moment
I'm in fact exactly but when you are
exploring that slack I would imagine
many people feel pressured whether it's
internal pressure or societal familial
pressure to get a real job to see
orthe themselves and there a lot of the
decisions are made out of fear they they
worry about being out on the streets or
it's a nebulous terror anxiety how did
you support yourself for instance while
you were traveling through Asia when
when you left school I totally
understand this anxiety and fear and
stuff but here's here's the thing I
think one of the many kind of life
skills you want to actually learn at a
fairly young age is the skill of being
like ultra thrifty minimal kind of this
little wisp that this traveling through
time in the sense of learning how little
you actually need to live not just in
kind of a survival mode but it kind of
you know in a contented mode and I
learned that pretty early by backpacking
and doing other things especially in
Asia was I could be very happy with very
very little and you could go on to
websites and stuff look at sir like the
minimum amount of stuff food say that
you need to to live you know your basic
protein carbohydrates and and vitamins
and and how much you actually if you
bought them in bulk how much it would
cost I mean you build your own house
live in a shelter a tiny house you don't
need very much and I think trying that
out you know building your house on the
pond like Thoreau whose era of mine in
high school is a not just a simple
exercise is too profound exercise
because it allows you to get over the
anxiety if you aren't living like that
you know that if the worst came to worst
you could keep going at a very low rate
and be content and so that gives you the
sort of confidence to take a risk
because you say what's the worst that
could happen well the words happened is
that I'd have a backpack in a sleeping
bag and I'd be eating oatmeal and you
know whatever you know and I'd be fine
yeah and I think if you do that once or
twice you don't necessarily have to live
like that but but knowing that you can
be content is tremendously empowering
definitely I did that's basically what I
did it was you know living in Asia where
the people around me had less than I did
and they were pretty content you realize
oh my gosh I don't really need very
to be happy and did you save up money
beforehand with odd jobs or did you do
odd jobs while on the road a bit of both
I did odd jobs before I left I was
traveling in Asia at a time when the
price differential was so great that it
actually made sense for me to fly back
on a charter flight to the US and work
for four or five months and I worked
basically odd jobs I worked from working
in a warehouse packaging athletic shoes
working in a kind of technical sense of
a it's a really just hard to describe
but it was kind of a in a photography
related job where we're reducing printed
circuit boards down to little sizes to
be shipped off to be printed and driving
cars to whatever else I could find and
that at that time made more money I
could live off of I could live out
probably two years mm-hmm from those
couple months of work so I didn't really
work while traveling until I got to Iran
in the late 70s and there there was a
very high paying job which was teaching
English mm-hmm to the iranian pilots who
worked for the shah but i had sworn
there was never going to teach english
so i actually got a job if benbella hot
helicopter who was teaching which is to
the pilots but my job was running a
little newsletter for the american
community there and I worked there until
I was thrown out by the coup that was
another story
why is that now just a couple of
comments so number one for those people
listening who are saying themselves
already perhaps creating reasons why
they can't do what you did now due to
different economic climate or whatnot it
is entirely possible to replicate what
you did you just have to choose your
locations wisely that for that type of
differential absolutely and I should
also just mention to people that part of
the reason I'm so attracted to stoic
philosophy whether that be Seneca or
Marcus Aurelius is exactly because of
the practice of poverty not because you
want to be poor but so that you
recognize not only that you can
Syst but then you can potentially be
content or even in some cases be more
content with a bare minimum so for
people who are more interested in that I
highly recommend a lot of the stoic
writings and you can search for those on
my blog and elsewhere but let me just
add to that there's actually a new-age
version of that that was sort of popular
in a generation ago and the search term
there is a volunteer simplicity hmm
volunteer simplicity right and so the
idea is poverty is terrible when it's
mandatory when you have no choice but
volunteer version of that is very very
powerful and I think attaching names
sometimes to things it makes it more
legitimate but but imagine yourself
practicing voluntary simplicity and that
I think is part of a stoic philosophy
but there's a whole kind of a movement a
lot of the hippy dropouts were kind of
practicing a similar thing and there was
you know the whole best practices that
resolved around that you can make up
your own but I think it's to be an
essential skill that a life skill that
people should acquire and when you go
backpacking and stuff like that that's
part of it that's the beginnings of
trying to understand what it is that you
need to live as a you know as a being
and you can fill that out in any way you
want but that's a good way to experiment
now you have become certainly a
world-class packager of ideas but also
at synthesizing and expressing these
ideas I love your writing if I've
consumed vast quantities of it in fact
I'm here right now on on Long Island
where I grew up and I used to sneak into
my parents shed to read old editions of
the Whole Earth Catalog for inspiration
it was it was the I suppose the
equivalent of my Internet at the time
and from that all the way to 1,000 true
fans which of course you know I sort of
shout from the rooftops for people to
read how did you develop that skill of
writing and communicating a lot of
people associate that with schooling but
it doesn't appear to be the source for
you yeah so in high school I would call
myself a very late bloomer I I don't
recall myself having a lot of ideas
there were a lot of other people and
kids in my high school that I was very
impressed with because they
to know what they thought and we're very
glib and particulate and and I and I
wasn't I was a little bit more visual on
that sense I was trying to decide
whether to go to art school or to MIT
because I was really interested in
science so I set off to Asia as a
photographer so it was you know
basically no words at all I was just
images and as I was traveling and seeing
these amazing things I mean again I want
to emphasize that this was sort of a for
me I grew up in New Jersey I never left
New Jersey we never took vacations it's
hard to describe how parochial New
Jersey was back in the 1960s I never had
eight Chinese food and never had I mean
I never saw a Chinese it was like it was
a different world and then I was thrown
into Asia and it was like oh my gosh
everything I knew is wrong and so that
education was extremely extremely
powerful and I think that that that gave
me something to say and I started
writing letters home and I tried to
describe what I was seeing and so I had
a reason to try to communicate and that
was the beginning of it but even then I
don't think I really had much to say it
wasn't really until the internet came
along hmm and I had a chance to go onto
one of the first online communities in
the early 80s and for some reason the
early 80s that is that is definitely
yeah it was really days yeah in 1981 and
so this were private that wasn't the
kind of wide open Internet these were a
little experiment the fact it was New
Jersey Institute of Technology in
Rutgers too had this experimental online
community that I got invited on and we
can talk about how that happened but
that was it was just luck and a friend
and I found that there was something
about the direct attempt to just
communicate with someone else in real
time you know just just sending them a
message or something that crystallized
my thinking so what it turned out is is
how did it crystallized your thinking
just not interrupt but was it an
immediate feedback loop it was the idea
that they have since teachers have since
done a lot of studies where they had
kids write an essay on something at an
assignment and then they would also be
instructed to write some email to a
friend or something and then they would
grade both of the compositions hmm and
they would find it inevitably the email
that the kids were writing was much
better writing hmm because when you're
trying to write a composition there's
all these you know we have all these
attitudes or expectations or this this
is kind of a right early sense this
there's all this other garbage and
luggage and baggage on top of that but
when we're just trying to send email
we're just we're directly trying to
communicate something we're not fooling
around we're not trying to be it make it
the literary literary all they were just
direct stuff and so the writing there
was always much more directed concrete
okay that's the that's the usual thing
that happens when you're trying to write
it or not concrete enough but when your
emails I call crank create and so it was
getting out of the whole kind of write
early stuff and just pure concrete
communication that really made it for me
and what I discovered which is what many
writers discover is that I write in
order to think yeah it was like I think
I have an idea
but when I begin to write it I realized
I have no idea and I don't actually know
what I think until I try to write it so
writing is a way for me to define out
what I think and serve it's like I don't
have any ideas that's true but when I
write I get the ideas and that was the
revelation and so by being forced to
communicate online and there was none of
this expectation was just like okay this
or any email I could do that
I don't have to write an essay I don't
to write something nice I'm just going
to write you know 140 characters I can
do that but while I was doing that I had
an idea that it had before mm-hmm and so
it was like oh my gosh this is a idea
generation machine it's by writing it's
not that I have these ideas I'm going to
write them down oh no I don't even have
them until I write I'm so glad you
brought that up because I was just
recently a few things related to that I
was reading an interview with Kurt
Vonnegut who's one of my favorite
authors for people who aren't familiar
check out cat's cradle perhaps as a
starting point hilarious guy and
he at various points in his career
taught writing to make ends meet and he
would number one not look for good
writers he would look for people who are
passionate about specific things so
that's that's something I want to
reiterate to people who don't feel right
early is that right
go out and have the experiences and find
the subjects the things that excite you
and as long as you're true to your voice
which is related to the email point I
threw out my first two drafts of that's
a third of the 4-hour workweek because
they were either too pompous and Ivy
League sounding to way way way too much
I mean horribly or too slapstick because
I felt like I had to go to the other
extreme and then I sat down and I wrote
as if I were composing an email to a
friend after two glasses of wine and
that's how I found my voice so to speak
as a side note why and I think this
might be related but why did you promise
yourself not to teach English I'm so
curious because that's a that can be
very lucrative it's readily available
when you are traveling why did you
commit to yourself not to teach English
yeah it's a good question because
there's lots of opportunities all around
the world and by the way I recommend it
as a way for people to travel cheaply if
you want to support yourself because it
is a very desirable skill we call it for
the moment I think the reason why was I
felt that I do feel like I was a very
good teacher and I also felt that it was
maybe a little easy mmm but I think the
main reason was that I was having
trouble imagining myself enjoying it you
know and I just felt that I would rather
try to find something else now I think I
did one time in Taiwan which as you know
has a whole cram school system I think a
friend a substituted for a friend once
and I think that may be confirmed to my
idea that while it was sort of like you
know all I have to do is this talk I
mean there's really not much skill
involved at all
it was fun but I didn't feel like I was
I don't know I didn't feel like I was
maybe adding value or something so I
came away thinking you know I guess I
could do this for money but I'm not
gonna be happy I think it's just the
personality thing I don't
think of myself as a teacher I don't do
many workshops or classes so I think a
different person might thoroughly enjoy
it and I know they do and they have a
great time doing it for me it was just
not for me
mm-hmm got it no big deal I think this
is an important thing is is that you
know it takes a long time to kind of
figure out what you're good for and part
of where I'm at right now and where I
got eventually was really trying to
spend time on doing things the only I
can do and even when I could do
something well but someone else could do
it
mmm I would try and let that go that
that's a discipline that I'm still
working on which is not just things that
I'm good at but things that only I'm
good at so that was something I was sort
of trying to start early on which is
like you know a lot of other people can
do this and they're happy doing it so I
want to go somewhere where it requires
more of me to do and then I'll be
happier and they'll be happier I am
currently having and I seem to have
these periodically a crisis of meaning
phase and I'm wrestling with this exact
issue trying to figure out what to
abandon what to say no to to refine my
focus so I can really focus on the
intersection of my unique capability or
capabilities whatever that is and a need
of some type how did you figure that out
and maybe we could approach it from a
different direction what do you feel is
your skill set or your your unique skill
and how did you figure that out well let
me tell you the story of how this
realization actually came to be in a
kind of a very concrete way was while I
was editing Wired magazine and so part
of what Wired magazine is about is is
that we would come up with ideas and
make assignments to writers now some of
the articles in Wired would come from
the writers themselves they would
approach us as hey I have an idea but a
lot of the the articles would be
assigned from editors we'd have
editorial meetings where we kind of
imagine this great article and then we
go and try and find someone to it to
write it and in in that conversation of
trying to persuade writers to write
an idea that I had they would go through
a kind of a very typical sequence where
you know I would have this great idea
this is great idea and then I would try
to persuade like one writer to write or
three writers and I would just you know
they didn't think was a very good idea
they didn't like it they didn't want to
do whatever was mm-hmm and then I'd kind
of forget about it but then like you
know six months later would come back
and say no that was such a great idea I
really think we should do that and I
would go again for the other round of
trying to persuade people and then I get
no takers and then I kinda get my that
must have been a bad idea but then like
six months later or a year later it
might come back you know that's still a
great idea nobody has done that and then
I would realize oh my gosh I need to do
that um it was like I'm the only one who
can see this I've tried to give it away
I have tried really hard to give it away
I've tried to kill it it just keeps on
coming back coming back it's like okay
and then I would do it and there'll be
one of my best pieces and so it was this
idea of like so I became really an
important proponent of trying to give
things away first mmm tell everybody
what you're doing basically you try to
give these ideas away and people are
happy because they love great ideas and
you do it it's a great idea you should
do it and so I try to give everything
away first and then I try to kill
everything it's like no that's a bad
idea
and then it's the ones that keep coming
back that I can't kill and I can't give
away I think hmm maybe that's the one
I'm supposed to do and just because no
one else is going to do it I mean I've
been I've been actively trying to get
and then of course if someone else is
doing it you should see someone else
competing or trying to do it it's like
oh yeah you go ahead do it I'm not gonna
race against you
yeah that's crazy because there's two of
us you know you do it and so um so
thanks that generosity is actually part
of this your vetting process exactly and
so that's when I kind of realized it but
that doesn't answer the question of well
how do you find out what it is and all I
can say is you know and I don't want to
be flipped but all I can say is this
going to take all your life to figure
that out right that is fact here's what
here's what is figuring out is what your
life is about
I mean that's what life is for right
life is to figure it out and then so
every part of your life every day is
actually disa tempt to figure this out
and you'll have different answers as you
go along and sometimes there may be
directions in that but that's basically
what it is and you are very transparent
about confessing this but I have to tell
you that even from hanging around a lot
of very accomplished people a lot of
successful people that we would be on
the covers of magazines they also go
through exactly the same questioning I
mean no matter how big of a
billion-dollar company they have they
they come up to the same thing well you
know what's what's my role in all this
why am I here what am i useful what am i
doing that nobody else can and it's a
it's a continuous in fact as we'll come
back to being successful makes it even
more difficult mmm why is that because
of the what I call the creators dilemma
which is very much the same thing as the
innovators dilemma mm-hmm which is that
it's a true dilemma in fact in the sense
that there's no right answer but the
question is is sort of is it better to
optimize your strengths hmm or to invest
into the unknown into places that were
your weak and any more places you
haven't explored yeah any accountant in
any business will tell you that it
absolutely makes more sense to take your
dollar because you'll get you know
you'll get a higher return by investing
into what you're good at
already whatever it is it is its pursuit
of excellence this is Tom Peters and the
whole entire movement which is you move
uphill you you keep optimizing what you
know and that by far is the sameness
that the most reasonable the the
smartest thing to do but when you have a
very fast changing landscape like we
live in right now you get stuck on an a
local Optima you get you get stuck
mm-hmm and the problem is is that the
only way you can get to a higher more
fit place is you actually have to go
down you actually have to head into a
place where you are
optimal you have no expertise there's
very low margins there's low profits you
look foolish
there'll be failures and if you've been
following a line of success that is very
very difficult to do it's very difficult
for an organization it's almost
literally almost a possible for
organization who's been excellent
successful to do it really is so which
results a lot of opportunity for the sy
the startups I'll start off these the
reason why startups start is because
they're operating in an environment that
no sane big corporation would want to be
in it's it's it's a market it's low
margins low profitability unproven high
failure I mean it's like who wants
operate there nobody there only reason
why startups I'll freeze they have no
choice right yeah it's the the gift of
few options right right exactly so in
terms of success binding I think you
have to be unsuccessful who it's
successful wants to be unsuccessful it's
very very hard to to let go of that
success and so that's one of the things
that works against someone really
continuing in the honors life journey
after finding out what they're really
good at because because here's the thing
is that successful companies and
successful people generally try to solve
problems with money you buy solutions
and we all know that money doesn't is
not the full answer for innovation you
know basically if you could purchase
innovations all the big companies would
just purchase them okay it's the fact
that that these innovations often have
to be found out without money through
other means
again that's the advantage to the
startup and it's a disadvantage to the
successful companies because they got
money and I just want to buy solutions
but you mostly solutions you can't buy
you have to kind of engineer in this
very difficult environment of low
margins low success low profits that no
one really wants to be in but the
startups are forced to be that's also an
advantage I would think for beginners or
novices compared to experts they have
less vested identity less inertia to
have to reverse and expect to buy
just in the meeting my slack and flowing
around when you're young is so important
because a lot of these innovations and
things are found not trying to solve a
problem that is can be monetized yeah
it's in exploring this area without
money I mean money is so overrated it
really could you elaborate on X I feel
like this is a sermon I need to receive
on some level there's several things to
say about it one is you know obviously
if you're struggling pay bills and
mortgages and stuff it there's a certain
amount that's needed but but here's the
thing is that accumulating enough money
to do things is really a byproduct of
other things it's a kind of a lubricant
in a certain sense rather than you know
a goal and great wealth or extreme
wealth is definitely overrated I've had
meals with a dozen billionaires and
they're no different I mean their lives
lifestyles are no different their
billions is you don't want to have a
billion dollars maybe put that way you
really don't you can't there's nothing
that you can really do with it that you
can't do with a lot of less money it was
a set that aside but even just wealth
itself in this world where there is more
and more abundance even the money for
say middle class is less significant in
a certain sense in the sense that maybe
there's status which is really not
needed but the things that you want to
do the things that will make you content
the things that will satisfy you the
things that will bring you meaning can
usually got better than having money I
mean if you have a lot of time or a lot
of money it's always better to have a
lot of time to do something and so if
you have a choice between having a lot
of friends or a lot of money you
definitely won't have a lot of friends
and so I think there's a way and even in
which the technological progress that
we're having is actually diminishing the
role of money and I want to be clear
that I'm talking about money beyond the
amount that you need to survive but even
that reflects back we were saying
earlier which is probably less than you
think it is that you survive and so in a
certain sense most people see money as a
means to get these other things but
there are other routes to these
things right that are deeper and more
constant and more durable and more
powerful so money is the sort of very
small one-dimensional thing that if you
kind of focus on that it kind of comes
and goes and if you whatever it is that
you're trying to attain you go to it
more directly through other means you'll
probably wind up with a more powerful
experience or whatever it is that you're
after and it'll be deeper more renewable
than coming at it with money and so you
know travel is one of the great examples
is which is you know many many people
who are working very hard trying to save
their money to retire someday to travel
well I decided to flip it around and
travel when I was really young when I
had zero money and you know I had
experiences that basically even a
billion dollars kind of bought right
Billy and and and it's not an uncommon
sight let me tell you for young kind of
travelers who have very little money to
be hanging out doing something and there
will be some very wealthy people on
there one week organized tour looking at
these young travelers just saying I wish
I wish I had more time yeah you see it
you see it every well I see it almost
every time I go traveling and it reminds
me of conversations I've had with Ralph
pots and also his book vagabonding which
I just absolutely love and it was it was
that book and Walden that I took with me
traveling when I had my own two year or
so walkabout and he points out in the
beginning of vagabonding that many
people subscribe to the belief along the
lines of Charlie Sheen's in the movie
Wall Street and when he's asked what
he's going to do when he makes his
millions and he says I'm kind of get a
motorcycle and ride across China
and Ralph of course points out that you
could you could clean toilets in the US
and save enough money to ride a
motorcycle across China exactly and the
the let me ask you this is this is maybe
tangentially related but you mentioned
earlier that you know your middle age
your middle ages from middle ages maybe
sounds odd but
you're middle-aged that's when you
optimize and I find that horrifying on
some level because I am so tired I just
turned 37 last week and I'm I'm really
tired of certain types of optimizing and
the incremental slogging of making
trains run slightly more efficiently on
time even though like you said from a
strictly financial standpoint the advice
that I would receive from many people
and have received when I've asked for
advice is here are one or two core areas
you should focus on to optimize for
income and on the flip side I'm tempted
to approach a kind of not scorched earth
but burned bridges approach where I
somehow use creative destruction to
force me into another direction
to have these new experiences that I
craved so much and you just for people
who aren't aware I want to give I
remember going to the first ever
quantified self Meetup you're part of
the long now foundation you've
experimented in so many different arenas
and have looked so far into the future
and thought on such grand scale you know
I aspire to do more of that what would
be your advice to someone and I know I
have dozens of friends in the same
position there say in their earlier
mid-30s in my particular peer group and
they want to explore but they're feeling
pressured to optimize this thing that
they've suddenly found their footing
with whenever it is that maybe they're a
venture capitalist maybe they're in a
startup they feel they should start a
new startup and they want to step out of
that slipstream what would be your
advice to those people first of all I
have to commend your honesty for this
and I will repeat that that it is very
very difficult to do I mean there I
think that realization is you know comes
to people middle-aged and they realize
oh my gosh you know I'm kind of on a
there's a little bit of a routine here
and I'm not really happy with that I
think that kind of you know scorched
earth kind of like you know just will
just set fire to it and will walk away I
actually have I think we probably have a
mutual friend I won't use his name
because I don't know how how how public
this is but but one of his solutions was
the most radical one I've ever heard
the force himself was that he gave up US
citizenship oh wow in that'll that'll do
it it was like he was like saying I just
feel so I know and it was like oh my
gosh that's so radical I he was telling
me about what's involved in that and it
wasn't for tax purposes because actually
before you can do it the u.s. actually
requires that you square upon all taxes
it was like but that was so radical and
I don't recommend that he's doing fine
but I'm saying that's that's unnecessary
but I think the advice is probably
taking a page from yourself I don't
think it's necessary to I think you can
experiment your way through this I mean
you can do this incrementally you can
you can take small steps and do
something and then evaluate it test how
I was going whether you're getting what
you want out of it whether it's working
and then you continue that direction and
that's sort of the pattern of people who
kind of you have second careers or
reinvent themselves you hear that a lot
and you can do that in a disciplined Tim
Ferriss way I don't think that it
requires you to kind of walk out and
leave a burning pile behind I think it's
something that you're going to I'm a big
believer in doing things deliberately
and I think that you begin by looking at
those areas that you get satisfaction
out of in those areas where I often find
that people kind of retreat back to kind
of things that they did as kids and
really really miss you know whether it's
art or other things and the truth is
that you're not really going to be able
to escape all the other things you have
going that's a good thing because that
is part of you and part of what you do
well so you'll probably just you know
bend in a certain direction and I think
the one bit of advice is that you can't
you know it's not gonna happen overnight
it's going to be it took you 37 years
ago where you are it may take you
another 30 years to get where you want
to go and I don't think you should feel
impatient maybe that's the word I'm
saying is is that I don't think you
should imagine that you'll have another
hat on with a new label you know next
year just to maybe redirect that and
this may or may not be accurate but in
the process of researching for
or this conversation which is sort of an
odd exercises in and of itself given how
much time we spend together but I came
across in Wikipedia mention of your
experience in Jerusalem and deciding to
live as though you only had six months
left and I want to touch on that but one
of the questions that came to my mind
when I turned 37 last week is if I knew
I were going to die at age 40 what would
I do to have the greatest impact on the
greatest number of people and so that I
find that constraint helpful and I worry
that if I aim at not being impatient in
that way and that I won't because I
could get hit by a bus that I won't do
what I'm capable of doing maybe you
could talk about and I had no idea I'm
not sure if you would self described
yourself as a devout Christian but
that's that's certainly written here
maybe you could talk a little bit about
that experience yeah so yeah one thing I
would course warn people is that not
everything on Wikipedia is correct no
that's why I'm bringing it out right but
but it but it is it's true that I got
this assignment in Jerusalem which by
the way if you want to hear the full
version of it listen to one of the very
first This American lives which I hire a
class and I told the story for the very
first time and it's a story about how I
got this assignment to live as if I was
going to die in six months even though I
was like perfectly healthy and I knew
that it was a really improbable but I
decided to take the assignment seriously
and that's that's what I did my answer
kind of surprised me because I thought
that I would kind of have this or Mad
high-risk fling you know do all these
things but actually what I wanted to do
was to visit my brothers and sisters go
back to my parents help out but then my
mom was not well at the time but that
lasted for three months before I decided
I need to do something big so I actually
rode my bicycle across the u.s. from San
Francisco to New York where I was going
New Jersey where I was going to
basically die and I kept a journal of
that and that question was something
that I keep asking myself now I actually
have a countdown clock
that Matt Groening at Futurama was
inspired and they did a little episode
on Futurama about and what I did was I
took the actuarial tables for the
estimated age of my death for someone
born when I was born and I worked back
the number of days and I have I have
that showing on my computer how many
days and I tell you nothing constant
rates your time like knowing how many
days you have left now of course I'm
likely again to live more than that I
mean good health etc but nonetheless
there is something that really you know
I have 6,000 something days it's not
very many days to do all the things I
want to do and so I think your exercise
is really fantastic and commendable and
there's two questions one day what would
you do if at six months living what
would you do if you had a billion
dollars and interestingly it's the
convergence of those two questions
because it turns out that you probably
don't need a billion dollars to do
whatever it is you have you're going to
do in six months right and so I think
you're asking the right question and and
the way I answer it is you want to keep
asking yourself that question every
every six months and really try to
answer it and I try to you know do that
on a kind of a day-by-day basis I
learned something from my friend Stuart
brand who organized his remaining days
around five-year increments he says any
great idea that significant that's worth
doing for him will last about five years
from the time he thinks of it to the
time he stopped thinking about it and if
you think of it in terms of five-year
projects you can count those off on you
know a couple hands for even if you're
young and so the sense of mortality of
understanding that it's not just old
people who don't have very many you know
you're twenty years old you don't have
that many five-year projects to do right
and so I think it is that's maybe part
of the the philosophy of thinking about
our time and whether even if you believe
in the extension of life longevity
living 220 you still have to think in
these terms of what you can do
you because you don't know if you'll
live on beyond your 20 we're going to do
if you have a year and what we do do
with a billion dollars and what's the
intersection of those if you want more
of the Tim Ferriss show you can
subscribe to the podcast on iTunes or go
to for our blog comm fo u Rho G , where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more
follow Tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or RSS or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss til next time thanks for
listening
you